[Musik]
und jetzt das heute journal mit heinz
wolf und marietta slomka
guten abend europa hat viel zu tun
nämlich noch kurz die welt retten den
eindruck konnte man gewinnen als eu
kommission chefin ursula von der leyen
heute ihre rede zur lage euro passiert
in anlehnung an die traditionellen reden
amerikanischer präsidenten gibt es ja
auch für die eu so genannte state of the
union reden einmal jährlich wird ein
großer bogen geschlagen was man erreicht
hat und wo die herausforderungen der
zukunft legen da hatte ursula von der
leyen heute eine ganze menge vorzutragen
die aktuelle und künftige pandemien
bekämpfen globaler vorreiter beim
klimawandel seien weltweit die
menschenrechte fördern den chinesen die
stirn bieten und generell in der außen
und verteidigungspolitik
enger zusammenrücken ein strammes
programm also aus straßburg anne
gellinek
ursula von der leyen hat wohl geahnt
dass ihre rede zur lage europas keine
großen emotionen erzeugen würde und sich
deshalb einen gast eingeladen der
tatsächlich für gänsehaut und standing
ovations
die italienische florettfechterin baby
gerade noch holte sie gold bei den
paralympics in tokio nun steht sie fast
ein wenig schüchtern im europaparlament
von der leyen will dass europa sich an
ihr ein beispiel nimmt das unmögliche
möglich machen das ziel nicht aus den
augen verlieren von der leyens rede ist
ein ritt durch die europapolitik die
impfstrategie zumindest jetzt wo 70
prozent der europäer geimpft sind ein
erfolg beim klimaschutz soll die eu
vorreiter sein auch wenn ja eigentlich
bislang nur vorschläge auf dem tisch
liegen und noch nichts beschlossen ist
immerhin habe europa einen plan andere
müssten jetzt mitziehen
europa ist bereit mehr zu tun aber wir
erwarten dass die usa und andere partner
sich auch stärker engagieren das ist
entscheidet
europas rolle in der welt ebenfalls ein
lieblingsthema der eu
kommissionspräsident in hat gerade in
afghanistan einen herben rückschlag
erlitten die lehre daraus könne aber nur
mehr europäische zusammenarbeit seien
auch beim militär das alleine aber
reiche noch nicht
sie können die modernsten truppen der
welt haben wenn sie nicht bereit sind
sie einzusetzen welchen nutzen haben sie
dann was uns bis jetzt zurückgehalten
hat ist nicht der mangel an militär
sondern das fehlen von politischem
willen
draußen vom parlament halten abgeordnete
der grünen die namen von menschen und
organisationen hoch die ins visier der
polnischen behörden geraten sind drinnen
kritisiert von der leyen die aushöhlung
des rechtsstaats ohne polen und ungarn
beim namen zu nennen schon in den
nächsten tagen werde sie erste schritte
einleiten um mittel aus dem eu haushalt
für polen und ungarn zu kürzen sagt sie
später auf nachfrage
wir müssen leider feststellen dass sie
das in der vergangenheit auch schon oft
gesagt hat aber sie tut es eben nicht
bis jetzt strafzahlungen gegen polen
beantragt wurden hat es über anderthalb
jahre gedauert die rede ist eine
mischung aus bilanz ankündigungen und
vorschlägen ohne visionen er
pflichtprogramm den längsten applaus
bekommt deshalb auch nicht ursula von
der leyen sondern die florettfechterin
die gold für italien und ein bisschen
auch für europa gewarnt
dann schalten wir noch zu anne gellinek
beim europäischen parlament in straßburg
an es ist ja doch schon interessant dass
von der leyen das also ausdrücklich über
rechtsstaatlichkeit sprach als als ein
europäischer werte die man verteidigen
werde war das nicht vielleicht auch eine
deutliche ansage richtung budapest und
warschau
das war eine ganz klare ansage richtung
polen und ungarn auch wenn sie die
beiden länder nicht namentlich genannt
genannt hat so ist doch klar dass der
streit um die rechtsstaatlichkeit mit
eben diesen beiden ländern und besonders
mit polen jetzt auf einen neuen
höhepunkt zu treibt die eu kommission
streitet sich auf gleich verschiedenen
feldern besonders mit polen sie hält
einerseits die korona hilfen die
wiederaufbauhilfen für polen zurück weil
sie sagt es ist nicht sicher dass die
gelder gegen korruption geschützt sind
andererseits hat die strafzahlungen beim
europäischen gerichtshof beantragt weil
polen ein urteil des europäischen
gerichtshofes nicht umsetzt und der
nächste punkt in der nächsten woche
würde eine neue eskalationsstufe
bedeuten denn dann entscheidet das
polnische verfassungsgericht darüber ob
es wirklich sein kann das eu-recht über
polnischem recht steht und die vermutung
der kommission ist dass der gerichts
dass der pater ist das polnische
verfassungsgericht nein sagen wird und
das kann die kommission auf keinen fall
so stehen lassen dann muss sie handeln
denn das berührt die innerste
verfasstheit der europäischen union wenn
ein land sagt wir erkennen urteile des
europäischen gerichtshofes nicht mehr an
schließlich was zu noch war noch ein
ganz andere frage abseits der regel
heute wie wird eigentlich in der eu in
brüssel oder straßburg auf die deutsche
bundestagswahl geschaut
alle reden darüber und alle wollen
natürlich wissen wer in zukunft das
größte und wirtschaftsstärkste land in
der europäischen union regiert heute
wurde zum beispiel schon vermutet dass
die tatsache dass von der leyen nicht
über die reform des stabilitätspaktes
und mögliche neue regeln für die
schuldenaufnahme gesprochen habe dass
das deutlich den deutschen wahlkampf
geschuldet sei ob das nun stimmt oder
nicht sei dahingestellt klar ist dass
alle wissen dass alle drei möglichen
potenziellen kandidaten im prinzip die
europäische politik von angela merkel
fortsetzen werden dass es da keinen
großen bruch gibt aber man macht sich
doch so ein bisschen sorgen darüber
welche koalition den zustande kommen
könnte von den südeuropäern hört man was
würde denn ein fdp finanzminister
bedeuten würde das heißen dass eine neue
sparpolitik kommt oder was würde eine
beteiligung der grünen heißen heißt das
dass dann die klimaziele weiter an
geschäft werden oder endlich der push
kommt für die klimapolitik also klar ist
alle machen sich sorgen und alle
fürchten einen gewissen stillstand der
sicherlich nach der bundestagswahl
antreten wird wenn es eine lange
regierungsbildung gibt das heißt dann
auch das hier in brüssel wenig
entschieden wird die einschätzung in
europa korrespondentinnen dankeschön an
einer straßburg bei ihrer werbung für
europa könnte der eu kommission entgegen
kommen das für die abtrünnigen briten
die wirtschaftlichen folgen des praxis
doch zunehmend spürbar werden und sich
das auch nicht mehr länger mit der
korona pandemie quasi weg erklären lässt
premierminister boris johnson steht
inzwischen so unter druck dass er heute
sein ein halbes kabinett austauschte das
sorgt zuerst mal für schlagzeilen und
ablenkung beseitigt aber ja nicht die
probleme etwa lehre ladenregale so wie
hier in diesem supermarkt ddr feeling in
manchester in vielen britischen leben
klaffen neuerdings solche lücken dass
das ist praktisch alltag geworden
lieferengpässe personalmangel die
a-nationalmannschaft wie sich der brh
exit bemerkbar macht
seit
1888 wird bei blossem in browns die
dreckige wäsche anderer leute gewaschen
vor allem die von hotels besitzer daniel
braun kann sich vor aufträgen kaum
retten allein ihm fehlen die
arbeitskräfte
der druck unter dem meine leute jetzt
arbeiten ist gewaltig sie versuchen mehr
zu schaffen als sie sollten das können
sie nicht durchhalten wir werden unser
geschäft herunterfahren müssen sonst
verliere ich auch noch diese
angestellten
seitdem wechselt haben zehntausende
europäer das land verlassen
in der pandemie ist das nicht
aufgefallen nun aber springt die
wirtschaft wieder an und die lebt in
großbritannien von dienstleistungen mehr
als eine million jobs sind nicht besetzt
daniel hat keine wahl er wird aufträge
absagen müssen das tut weh
ich habe einfach niemanden um diese jobs
zu machen und meine kunden sagen mir
dann wenn du uns nicht mehr beliefert
müssen wir zu machen
in portugal hotel in notting hill zeit
managerin christina die letzten
geplanten kissenbezüge sie braucht nun
eine neue wäscherei auch findet sie kein
personal und alles was aus der eu kommt
braucht seitdem dragset länger und
kostet mehr geld und mühe wir
wollen doch jetzt wieder richtig
loslegen und uns nicht darum sorgen ob
die zuckertüten ankommen oder die
bademäntel rechtzeitig da sind und vor
allem will ich meinen gästen einen
kopfkissenbezug bieten können ein hotel
ohne leinen ist kein hotel
auch ohne lebensmittel kommt man nicht
weit auf den feldern verrottet das
gemüse niemand da ist es zu pflücken
oder in die supermärkte zu
transportieren viele räder stehen still
gesucht werden 100.000 lkw fahrer der in
der branche arbeitet kann über nacht 40
prozent mehr gehalt verlangen
ja erst mal klingt super aber natürlich
wird für alle alles teurer werden diese
kosten müssen weitergegeben werden die
transportbranche kann das nicht
auffangen
panikmache nannte die britische
regierung all das vor dem referendum
doch nun geht auch hier die panik um
laut dragset vertrag müssen europäische
waren bei der einfuhr nach
großbritannien kontrolliert werden doch
aus angst vor noch mehr engpässen gerade
an weihnachten wurden nun alle
kontrollen ins jahr 2022 verschoben take
control ist erst mal abgesagt wir können
noch so viel geld anbieten es kommt
trotzdem keiner die briten wollen diese
jobs nicht sie finden sie nicht
attraktiv tatsache ist wir haben einen
pool an arbeitskräften verloren der
großbritannien stark gemacht hat sie
sind zurück nach europa und werden nun
europa stark machen
der einzige weg aus dem schlamassel da
sind sich die meisten unternehmer einig
wäre es zuzugeben dass man die europäer
doch braucht aber so weit ist die
regierung in london dann doch noch nicht
großbritannien hat nicht nur exit
probleme auch die korona lage ist wieder
angespannt im schnitt über 30.000 neue
fälle pro tag und inzwischen auch wieder
doch deutlich steigende tendenzen bei
krankenhauseinweisungen dort liegen
hauptsächlich ungeimpfte die impfquote
in großbritannien ist mit 64 prozent
ähnlich hoch so niedrig wie in
deutschland
wobei es dabei uns ja durchaus regionale
unterschiede gibt am niedrigsten sind
die impfquoten in den ostdeutschen
bundesländern beispiel thüringen dort
ist in manchen landkreisen noch nicht
mal die hälfte geimpft fragt sich wie
die bundesweite aktionswoche dort
ankommt florian kojak beobachtet dass
dann bitte noch eine formel stunden
warten ja heute wird gepiekst wo sonst
getanzt wird das schützenhaus thema
kurzerhand umfunktioniert zur impfstelle
eine aktion im landkreis hildburghausen
wo gerade mal 44 prozent vollständig
geimpft sind so wenig wie nirgendwo
sonst den thüringern und sogar die die
heute gekommen sind klingen nicht gerade
überzeugt
[Musik]
das ist einfach keine lust mehr habe auf
diese ganzen einschränkungen
die testerei dass nach der auch leute
mich nicht impfen lassen auch wenn man
normales leben führen will heute
die wenigsten hier scheinen sich der
gesundheit wegen impfen zu lassen die
wenigsten hier scheinen vertrauen zu
haben in die maßnahmen der politik
thüringens gesundheitsministerin kennt
das problem ich kann verstehen dass der
ein oder andere vielleicht so fühlt aber
insgesamt sind wir als gesellschaft
gefragt wir wollen insgesamt alle
gemeinsam wieder in den urlaub fahren
wir wollen geschützt sein wir wollen
gerne dass menschen die sich eben nicht
impfen lassen können dass sie nicht
gefährdet sind und deswegen gehört es
dazu dass jeder einzelne sich hier auch
überzeugen lässt wie nehmen menschen die
pandemie war damit beschäftigt sich
regelmäßig die cosmo studie der uni
erfurt ihre aktuellen daten zeigen von
den bislang ungeimpften geben 56 prozent
an sich nicht impfen lassen zu wollen 24
prozent seien noch unsicher oder
zögerlich und 20% eigentlich im bereit
da muss man nochmal ran und aufklären
über den eigenen nutzen den sozialen
nutzen die sicherheitsbedenken
adressieren also auch wenn man denkt das
ist schon 20 mal passiert es reicht
einfach immer noch nicht und es müssen
bestimmte gruppen erreicht werden die
bis jetzt schlecht erreicht wurden
menschen mit niedriger bildung mit
migrationshintergrund das sind ganz
wichtige gruppen außerdem sei die
impfbereitschaft im osten der republik
deutlich niedriger als im westen um die
menschen gerade in ländlicheren regionen
besser zu erreichen sind diese woche
auch wieder im busse unterwegs wie in
der thüringischen rhön
ich gehe auf montage das ist auch noch
mal schwierig und weiß dass so ein
angebot ist natürlich ganz prima
leichtigkeit dass man jetzt die einfach
einen termin einfach da sein kann
einfach herkommen kann sich impfen lässt
und dann wieder gehen kann im
stundentakt tingeln jana echl und ihr
team von dorf zu dorf mit großem
politischen aktionen glaube ich komme
nicht mehr weiter das ist jetzt klein
klein ich habe immer gesagt die ersten
60 prozent die wollen wir so
einigermaßen kriegen die kommen von
alleine und alles andere ist richtig
harte arbeit und das ist jetzt mal mit
mehr mal mit weniger erfolg wie hier in
oepfershausen wo heute kein einziger zum
im bus kam
viele infos rund um corona zum beispiel
welche regeln aktuell in den
verschiedenen bundesländern gelten
finden sie auf zdf heute und die
aktuellen corona zahlen für deutschland
hat jetzt keines wolf und zwar zu den
neuinfektionen und zu den aufnahmen in
kliniken das robert koch institut meldet
12 1455 kroner neuinfektionen binnen 24
stunden das sind 1110 weniger als
vergangenen mittwoch 83 todesfälle kamen
hinzu die sieben tage incidents sinkt
auf
77,96
128 weitere corona infizierte mussten
seit gestern ins krankenhaus damit
steigt die hospitalisierung rate auf
1,88 der bisherige höchstwert lag im
dezember 2020 bei knapp 16
angesichts der korona situation hat die
bundesregierung den vereinfachten zugang
zum kurzarbeitergeld bis zum jahresende
verlängert so werden die
sozialversicherungsbeiträge bis ende des
jahres voll erstattet mit der
vorliegenden verordnung wolle man dafür
sorgen dass die brücke der kurzarbeit
weiter bis zum jahresende trage und
arbeitsplätze sicherer sagt der
arbeitsminister heil bisher sind
erleichterungen beim zugang zum
kurzarbeitergeld auf betriebe begrenzt
die bis zum 30 september kurzarbeit
einführen ein weiterer
kabinettsbeschluss betrifft die
anpassung der hartz-iv-sätze ab januar
kommenden jahres der regelsatz für
alleinstehende erwachsene steigt demnach
von
446 auf
449 euro monatlich für partner und
ehegatten ebenfalls um 3 auf
404 euro sozialverbände kritisierten die
erhöhung als völlig unzureichend
der hamburger erzbischof heese soll im
amt bleiben trotz pflichtverletzungen
beim umgang mit missbrauchsfällen wegen
derer er papst franziskus seinen
amtsverzicht angeboten hatte diese habe
während seiner zeit als generalvikar und
personalverantwortlicher im erzbistum
köln persönliche verfahrensfehler
gemacht fälle sexualisierter gewalt aber
nicht mit absicht vertuscht so der
vatikan auf die entscheidung lese im amt
zu lassen reagierten das zentralkomitee
der deutschen katholiken und die
reformbewegung wir sind kirche mit
unverständnis und kritik
in den haag hat 20 jahre nach dem
kosovo-krieg der erste strafprozess vor
dem sondertribunal begonnen angeklagt
ist sally mustafa ex kommandeur der
albanischen miliz kosovo-befreiungsarmee
uck ek der 49 jährige der unter anderem
der folter und des mordes an gefangenen
im april 1999 beschuldigt wird weist die
vorwürfe zurück im kosovo-konflikt der
zur loslösung der provinz von serbien
führte wurden 13.000 menschen getötet
mit den balkankriegen ende der 90er
jahre begann für die deutsche bundeswehr
eine neue ära der auslandseinsätze der
längste in afghanistan ist ja gerade auf
bittere weise zu ende gegangen nach
afghanistan schauen wir gleich auch noch
doch zuerst auf einer überraschenden
mitteilung die die
bundesverteidigungsministerium heute
machte und zwar per twitter was in
berlin zusätzlich für irritationen
sorgte annegret kramp karrenbauer stellt
offenkundig den einsatz der bundeswehr
in mali in frage in dem
westafrikanischen land ist sie ja noch
und der einsatz dort gilt als besonders
gefährlich frank buchwald berichtet heiß
staubig brandgefährlich die
ausbildungsmission der bundeswehr in
mali gehört zu den risikoreichsten
einsätzen weltweit seit heute nachmittag
aber 15 uhr 5 steht die mission in frage
auf twitter äußert genau um diese zeit
die verteidigungsministerin massive
zweifel
sollte sich die zusammenarbeit von mali
mit russischen söldner gruppen
bestätigen stellt das die grundlagen des
mandats der bundeswehr für - ma und tm
in frage und gemeinsam mit dem bundestag
müssten wir konsequenzen ziehen die
abgeordneten des bundestages jedoch
völlig überrascht die opposition empört
wir fordern eine evaluierung eine
exit-strategie ja aber die sind eine
parlamentsarmee das heißt es muss im
bundestag es muss mit dem auswärtigen
amt gesprochen werden weiß die kanzlerin
davon also ich finde es sehr unseriös
zehn tage vor einer bundestagswahl
wirklich weltpolitik einfach mal über
ein tweet hinaus zu schicken
hintergrund nach einem militärputsch
winter in bamako offenbar seltener der
russischen sicherheitsfirma war kna ins
land holen die truppe unabhängige bilder
gibt es kaum gilt als äußerst brutal
ihre blutspur zieht sich von der ost
ukraine bis zentralafrika offiziell eine
privatarmee ein direkter draht zum kreml
aber wird ihr nachgesagt feststeht
präsident putin baut den russischen
einfluss in afrika aus vor zwei jahren
empfänger in sotchi 30 afrikanische
staatschefs auch deshalb beobachten
viele die entwicklung in mali mit einem
mulmigen gefühl
anschein will vladimir putin ihr auch
einen spaltkeil in der europäische union
hineintreiben aber den helfern in baku
muss eins ganz klar sein es kann nicht
sein dass man einerseits mit einer soll
darüber zusammenarbeiten will die sich
nicht ums kriegsvölkerrecht und
menschenrechte scheren wird und
andererseits von der europäischen union
erwartet dass sie die streitkräfte
marlies ausbildet auch im auswärtigen
amt beobachtet man die lage in marley
ziemlich beunruhigt
ich kann fürs auswärtige amt sagen dass
wir kenntnisse über russische gespräche
mit der malischen regierung haben und
auch die jüngsten medienmeldungen über
mögliche bilaterale militärkooperation
zur kenntnis genommen haben wir befinden
uns zu diesem ganzen themenkomplex im
austausch mit unseren europäischen
partnern so klingt die deutsche drohung
mit dem ende der mission auch nach einem
warnschuss für die regierung in bamako
in berlin aber wächst die sorge dass der
einsatz in afrika ähnlich enden könnte
wie der in afghanistan
der manni einsatz hat soweit nicht das
ausmaß wie es der in afghanistan hatte
allerdings kann man in afghanistan ja
sehen was passiert wenn der westen
komplett das feld räumt heute vor einem
monat rückten die taliban in den
präsidentenpalast in kabul ein zwei
wochen später zog offiziell der letzte
us soldat aus afghanistan ab dazwischen
spielten sich die bekannten evakuierungs
dramen ab vor den entsetzten augen der
weltöffentlichkeit
seitdem beschäftigen sich die taliban
damit ihre macht zu festigen das land im
inneren wieder nach ihrem gusto zu
formen und nach außen kontakte zu suchen
bevorzugt zum echten die da keine
berührungsängste haben die china oder
russland
katrin eigendorf ist für uns in kabul
und hat für heute einen sehr speziellen
interview termin mit dem haupt
sprachrohr der taliban kabul heute
mittag wir sind unterwegs in der
afghanischen hauptstadt
verkehrschaos und mittendrin kinder die
sich an unser auto hängen verzweifelt um
geld betteln überlebenskampf ist alltag
für viele menschen in den straßen
überall schwer bewaffnete kämpfer
wir haben eine verabredung mit dem
sprecher der taliban sabiullah
mudschahid er hat uns ein exklusives
interview zugesagt wir sprechen direkt
die soziale lage an der taliban sprecher
erklärt dass die gerade zugesagten
hilfszahlungen nicht ausreichend
der winter wird kommen und wir brauchen
noch mehr geld
deutschland fordert die einhaltung von
menschenrechten und dass die taliban
andere politische kräfte in die
regierung einbeziehen wird das in kabul
gehört
deutschland ist ein sehr wichtiges land
und meine bitte ist das ein solches auch
realistisch ist das afghanische volk
erwartet dass ihr unsere legitimität
anerkennen ohne uns dafür harte
bedingungen aufzuzwingen oder sich in
unsere inneren angelegenheiten
einzumischen
schwer bewaffnete kämpfer
spezialeinheiten der taliban sichern
jetzt alle öffentlichen gebäude auch das
informationsministerium in dem unser
interview stattfindet die hüter über die
neue ordnung wirken furchterregend
taliban sprecher mudschahid dagegen gibt
sich versöhnlich diplomatisch was sagt
er zu den brutalen angriffen auf
demonstrierende frauen die die
einhaltung ihrer rechte fordern welche
frauen werden nicht mehr angegriffen es
wird ihnen nichts geschehen es gab vor
ein paar tagen einen protest da war das
notwendig um die situation zu
kontrollieren
werden mädchen weiter zur schule gehen
können auch ältere über 12 13 jahre alte
bildung bekommen und auch die
universität besuchen können
das läuft über mobile erlauben jedem
mädchen seine bildung fortzusetzen
sowohl in der schule als auch college
alle bildungseinrichtungen werden offen
sein für jede frau
was ist doch die frauen die wir heute in
einem park in kabul sprechen erzählen
alle von ihrer angst in zukunft ihre
rechte zu verlieren werden die hardliner
unter den taliban siegen wie sie hier
fürchten es gibt angeblich eine spaltung
innerhalb der führung ist das richtig
frage istanbuler mutter
wir haben das in den sozialen medien
gesehen aber das sind alles lügen wir
hatten nicht den geringsten streit es
hat keinen konflikt zwischen uns gegeben
der mann der inzwischen zum wichtigsten
sprachrohr der taliban geworden ist
wirbt für gute beziehungen dafür
afghanistan nicht international zu
isolieren
seine worte werden an taten gemessen
werden müssen und fraglich ob sich die
versöhnlichen töne dauerhaft durchsetzen
es sind reporter einsätze wie diese für
die unsere kollegin katrin eigendorf in
diesem jahr mit dem hanns joachim
friedrichs preis ausgezeichnet wird die
jury lobt ihren mut ihr können und das
feingespür mit dem sie über die menschen
in afghanistan berichtet und die jury
nennt sie eine tragende säule
öffentlich-rechtlicher
krisenberichterstattung
katrin war in ihrer journalistenlaufbahn
für uns auch schon an anderen
schwierigen einsatzorten und wir freuen
uns sehr mit ihr über diese
herausragende auszeichnung ein weiterer
hanns joachim friedrichs preis geht an
den dokumentarfilmer karl gierstorfer
für seine pandemie doku charité
intensivstation 43 die in der ard
ausgestrahlt wurde und
jetzt nochmal heinz wolf zunächst mit
einer aktuellen meldung vom abend wer in
der stadt hagen in nordrhein westfalen
hat die polizei am abend eine synagoge
umstellt wie die polizei dortmund
mitteilte lägen hinweise über eine
mögliche gefährdungslage im zusammenhang
mit einer jüdischen einrichtung vor man
stünde in engem kontakt mit der
jüdischen gemeinde ein polizeisprecher
sagte es seien einsatzkräfte vor ort
nähere angaben sollten aus
einsatztaktischen gründen aber nicht
gemacht werden heute und morgen ist yom
kippur der höchste jüdische feiertag
zur börse heute war unter anderem der
blick nach china interessant auch aus
sicht der deutschen wirtschaft denn
china hat schwächere konjunkturdaten
gemeldet und außerdem walhalla wird die
entwicklung bei einem großen
chinesischen
immobilienkonzern aufmerksam verfolgt ja
dabei geht es um evergreen den
zweitgrößten immobilienentwickler china
ist er steckt in einer tiefen tiefen
krise den konzern droht das geld
auszugehen
anleger sorgen sich dass in china die
immobilienblase platzen und vielleicht
sogar einige banken in mitleidenschaft
gezogen werden könnten in der
firmenzentrale kommt es seit tagen zu
tumulten anleger immobilienkäufer und
lieferanten fordern ihr geld zurück
kunden sorgen sich dass ihre wohnungen
nie gebaut werden immobilien für die sie
wie üblich in china im voraus bezahlt
haben der konzern ächzt unter einem
schuldenberg von mehr als 300 milliarden
dollar waren selbst schon vor
liquiditäts und ausfallrisiken auf den
ersten blick ist aber grant ein
immobilienentwickler auf den zweiten
aber ein unübersichtliches
firmengeflecht aus weit über 200
tochterunternehmen die kredite sind kaum
durchschaubar auch an der börse schaut
man sorgenvoll nach china wegen der
schon wegen der schuldenkrise begrenzt
aber auch weil heute eben schwächere
konjunkturdaten aus dem land gemeldet
wurden millionen menschen in china sind
von ever grant abhängig kunden
mitarbeiter außerdem investieren viele
chinesen in wohneigentum wenn also die
immobilienblase platzen sollte steht
auch für die chinesische staatsführung
einiges auf dem spiel experten gehen
daher davon aus dass ist die chinesische
regierung so weit nicht kommen lässt und
zur hilfe eilt valerie haller vielen
dank und jetzt die zahlen vom lotto am
mittwoch sie lauten wie immer ohne
gewähr 8 21
27 37 40 41 superzahl 5 ein weiterer
gewinnzahlen finden sie auf lotto punkt
zdf de und im zdf text auf seite 55 7
es gibt unwetterwarnungen des deutschen
wetterdienstes vor schweren gewittern
mit heftigem starkregen und hagel
aktuell für teile von südbayern
ein ergebnis aus der
fußball-champions-league borussia
dortmund hat am abend bei besiktas
istanbul 2 1 gewonnen und mehr zum
ersten spieltag der gruppenphase dann
und 23 uhr im sportstudio uefa champions
league
in new york haben am berühmten broadway
die theaterhäuser nach 18-monatiger
corona pause ein comeback gefeiert damit
war es die längste pause in der mehr als
150-jährigen geschichte des broadway
gestern fanden aufführungen von gleich
vier großen hit musicals wie etwa lion
king oder briketts statt
einlass in die ausverkaufte säle war nur
zuschauern gestattet die vollständig
geimpft waren und am platz maske tun
das was wir uns gleich nach dem wetter
geht's weiter mit zdfzoom was tun gegen
den klimawandel und um 0.50 meldet sich
dann gundula gause mit unserem hatte
schneider update wir melden uns morgen
auf wiedersehen für diesel
[Musik]
ein schokolade und herzlich willkommen
zum wetter heute war ein rechts nasser
tag es hat häufig geregnet und das liegt
an diesem tief was uns einmal nach osten
hin überquert hat aber dessen kaltfront
ist noch bei uns und die drückt sich
dann im laufe der nacht und morgen im
tagesverlauf weiter an die alpenrand und
vor allem morgen wird es dann im süden
kräftig regnen teils mit gewittern
schauen wir erstmal in die kommende
nacht und da regnet es im osten
deutschlands teils mit gewittern
durchsetzt und ähnliches programm gibt's
im süden ansonsten halten sich viele
wolken örtlich bildet sich nebel tiefste
werte vor allem im westen bis 11 grad
ansonsten zum beispiel im osten
deutschlands bei 17 grad morgen also im
norden schauer die von nordwesten her
reinziehen ansonsten haben wir es auch
im osten mit schauern zu tun die gehören
noch zu kaltfront ansonsten gibt es
viele wolken nach westen hin aber
durchaus auf sonnenschein ja im süden
sieht wiederum ganz anders aus hier
drückt sich die kaltfront weiter an die
alpenrand in den abendstunden bilden
sich dann kräftige schauer und gewitter
und hier kannst dann auch dann
ordentlich schütten ganz im westen wird
sich dann die sonne größtenteils
durchsetzen bei höchsten temperaturen
bis 24 grad im südosten deutschlands
bevor die kaltfront kommt und 18 grad
ganz im norden deutschlands ja und die
nächsten tage es gibt weitere schauer
ganz im norden deutschlands aber
insgesamt wird es am freitag ruhiger bis
22 grad und vor allem am sonntag wird es
nicht mehr ganz so war mit 13 bis 20
grad ein schöner abend